Mark Zuckerberg just had to testify
before the Senate and he was
grilled by Senator Josh Holly on the uh
awful effects especially for young
people and he was asked to make an
apology so you didn't take any action
you didn't take any action you didn't
fire anybody you haven't compensated a
single victim let me ask you this let me
ask you this there's families of victims
here today have you apologize to the
victims I would you like to do so now
well they're here you're on National
Television would you like now to
apologize to the victims who have been
harmed by your product show them the
pictures would you like to apologize for
what you've done to these good
[Applause]
people no one have to go through the
things that your families have have
suffered and this is why we invested so
much and are going to continue doing
industry leting efforts to uh to make
sure that no one has to go go through
the types of things that your families
have had to
suffer you know why Mr Zuckerberg why
should your company not be sued for this
why is it that you can claim you hide
behind a liability Shield you can't be
held accountable shouldn't you be held
accountable
personally I thought Zuckerberg handled
this beautifully actually Hol is asking
a legitimate question which is hey you
your technology has led to all sorts of
terrible consequences from young people
and you haven't done enough to fix it so
should you apologize to these the
parents of these young people who have
been so hurt or in some cases perhaps
killed themselves and instantly
Zuckerberg gets up they start to stand
up he stands up and he apologizes this
looked really good it is the right thing
to do and moreover I don't think
Zuckerberg Bears most of the
blame
it social media is generally terrible
for young people in some some cases it
can be good if it's really really
tightly controlled if you're like
listening to the Michael N show right
now and you're a member of the in the
Inner Circle and you're you in the chat
with very wholesome smart people okay
that can be good but if you're a young
person and you're on Tik Tok or you're
on Tumblr you're on any of these other
plat I don't know if do people do Tumblr
anymore I don't know I interviewed a a
an ex who said that Tumblr radicalized
her but I don't know maybe they're
probably on some other one now all of
those Instagram Facebook obviously both
own by Mark Zuckerberg all of them can
lead you down a very bad path how are
they getting on those
Technologies that's my question I don't
want to point fingers at the parents
necessarily but parents are a big part
of it are the parents buying their kids
smartphones bad idea really bad idea
they shouldn't be doing that it's crazy
crazy to do that
today these smartphones are portals to
hell and if you are adult and educated
and well fored formed maybe you can
avoid the worst of it maybe if you're
very disciplined about your social media
use and you're not too curious and you
know you develop good habits maybe you
can avoid the Temptations in that portal
to Hell All Sorts by the way I'm not
even just talking about like weird sex
stuff which is probably what most people
think of when they they think about the
Temptations of the internet but all of
it all sorts of crazy stuff sloth you're
just Doom scrolling forever you know you
get addicted just to the those dopamine
hits or or you know you're just sending
out vicious awful things on Twitter and
there's so it's just pride of you're
just obsessed with your image and
posting pictures of your spaghetti or
whatever every deadly sin is
is a major Temptation on social media
why would a parent do
that I'll tell you why because the
parents need to reach the kids okay get
the kid a flip phone well no no you
don't understand Michael the kids
friends the kids friends all have the
smartphones okay well why do your kids
friends have smartphones why are they
friends with those people well because
the their kids are in public school okay
I get it man it's really hard private
schools very very expensive and PR and
in most cases really not not any better
than the public schools in that regard
and maybe you want a homeschool but you
need the money so you got to go out to
work there's no one to homeschool or
there's not a good homeschooling Co-op
near you or there's this or there's that
or I know the system is set up against
you I'm I'm not denying any of that but
we can't just go along to get along
anymore with these sorts of
issues this is not like techn
technological advancements when you were
a kid same thing that's being taught in
schools we say oh the schools have
always been leftwing yeah they weren't
chopping kids genitals off 20 years ago
actually that's a that's a marked change
and so 20 years ago you send your kid to
public school all right they're probably
going to turn a little Lefty but what
are we going to do yeah now they're
going to chop your kids genitals off so
that's a that's now you can't now the
calculation changes and it is incumbent
upon you to figure something out and
it's incumbent Upon Us in the political
order to figure something out but it is
not all Mark Zuckerberg's fault I'm no
big promoter of Facebook and obviously
of social media at all are these Tech
zillionaires but and this guy you know
Zuckerberg may have been one of the most
significant factors in kicking Donald
Trump out of the white house so I I
there's no love lost here for Mark
Zuckerberg but it is not all that guy's
fault a Navy veteran this guy Michael
Cassidy's 35 years old he's the guy who
beheaded the satanic statue that was
exalted in the Iowa state capital that
man has been charged with a hate
crime beheading a a satanic statue
erected in the capital is now a hate
crime are we the baddies I keep asking
this question it keeps coming coming up
is is Joe Biden more evil a ruler than
xiin ping or Vladimir Putin I know the
latter two guys they're bad they do all
sorts of bad stuff I know but like we we
throw military veterans into prison or
we're going to try to throw some
military veterans into prison
for objecting to a satanic Idol in a
government building and like a really
prominent government building are
we is Satanism now a protected religion
it's not a religion first of all not
even the satanists think that they are
in a religion the satanic temple says
that it is ironic they're just a bunch
of edgy Reddit atheists they don't they
believe that they're not actually
worshiping the devil the secret is they
are worshiping the devil because you
can't ironically worship the devil but
they think that they're atheists they
don't think they're a religion religion
is a habit of virtue that inclines the
will to render to God the worship that
he deserves by no even remotely
plausible definition of religion do
these satanists
qualify Christians qualify I think Jews
can make a good case of qualifying I
think Muslims can make a good case of
qualifying even the non-theistic
religions Hinduism and
Buddhism can can make a less plausible
but still somewhat plausible case of
qualifying as a
religion these guys don't because they
say we're not
religious but second of all even if they
really were worshiping Satan that would
be worse and at no other point in
American history would we tolerate this
the founding fathers liberal-minded men
are rolling over in their graves
thinking about
this and then the third part it it just
keeps getting more outrageous the third
part is there are regularly attacks on
churches in America that basically go
unpunished vandalism
attacks from Street criminals and from
the government the government shuts down
churches
too all during Co they tried to shut
down down the churches and the
synagogues for that
matter that no no big deal there there
are no face act prosecutions by the bid
Administration for that no no no we've
got to protect religious liberty only in
one case and the religious liberty we're
protecting is the religious liberty of
satanists are we the baddies are we the
baddies Nations can go bad I hope we're
not
bad I I would love my country no matter
what the political leaders are doing
because it's my country and it's an
extension of filial piety but
it's getting very difficult to defend
this but xiin ping persecutes the
Muslims he does Vladimir Putin he you
know he's really bad I know he's really
bad he annexes territory that the Soviet
Union used to have I know it's bad it's
bad not defending
it we we take kids away from their
parents because the parents won't
pretend they're the opposite sex you
know sometimes leading to their suicide
we uh arrest pro-lifers for praying in
abort centers we arrest them and
sentence them to over a decade in prison
and now we protect the rights of
satanists the so-called religious rights
of satanists more than than any other
religion any actual religion as far as I
can tell and we try to imprison Navy
Veterans for
that are we the baddies H it's a
question that we men have to ask
ourselves man what a great clip that was
now hold up ring that Bell subscribe to
the Michael NS YouTube channel we'll see
you next time